Maggie is starting this hour off in
Florida hi Maggie how are you hi babe hi
what's are you okay well I have a
question for you
we are in the process of buying a
business and you already have a
pre-approval from the bank but we
haven't been able to come down to
agreement with the owner as far as the
terms and we have a letter of intent but
basically what they want is earnest
money with the cause of not being
responsible and you can't get a loan but
I mean the bank has given us a
pre-approval but we can't just give
$25,000 and not know if for sure we're
getting it or not so they gave us the
option of maybe a non-exclusive letter
of intent while we get the you know the
hundred-percent guarantee that were
getting the loan and it starts with
diligence but they also have another
bidder so I don't know that would be
something so much loss people or not
okay well there's two or three things
that help anyone in a negotiation one is
he with the most information wins - is
he with the most patients wins and three
he with other options wins they have
other options at least they think want
you to think they do and you've you are
desperately trying to please someone in
order to give them a pile of money
you're your I can just tell by talking
to you you're you're in a weakened
emotional state in this negotiation so
what I would propose is is that a
$25,000 earnest money that is refundable
on the term sheet based on the
contingency of financing is a normal
deal if you guys don't want to go to
contract on that then go with your other
buyer no I'm not giving some my $25,000
and then screw around and get me on used
my contract my offer to go get somebody
else up and get the other deal done
they're gonna use your deal to shop it
and get the price up that's exactly what
they're doing so who is this where'd you
find this business to buy this for sale
whoa no how'd you find it shopping
school a driving school and what does it
what is the net profits on this driving
school in a year
net profit well that without being the
owners do you pay like from there we
would you know take her salary okay so
if you were to if I were to operate it
from Tennessee and I paid people
salaries to run the thing what would be
my net profit if I were an absentee
investor I mean they profit really well
that's what the P&L says have you seen
tax return shitty yes tax return you
understand I'm not talking about gross
revenues I'm talking about profit well
earnings before taxes and depreciation
is alone two hundred and fifty to three
hundred thousand a year without without
anybody being paid but the owner
actually works there the owner actually
works there no okay so all right so what
are you offering to pay for this
business 50,000 okay it's a reasonable
price if it's truly netting 250 and all
the salaries have been paid to operate
the business by an absentee owner okay
so that's not a reason ton reasonable
pricing 25,000 is not an unusual earnest
money and you're borrowing money to buy
this business
yeah okay how much are you borrowing 90%
okay well you do what you want I
wouldn't buy the business I wouldn't go
into that far into debt to buy driving
school I won't go that foreign debt to
buy anything I think that's a mistake
but as far as the actual question you
asked me I would tell them to accept the
deals on the term sheet that's what a
letter of intent is it's a term sheet it
lays out the terms of the deal the terms
of the deal were contingent upon your
financing and the contract needs to read
that it's contingent upon your financing
and I wouldn't put up earnest money
otherwise and I would not take it with
them having a non-exclusive and are you
having a non-exclusive and I'm having
the right to shop your deal and try to
get more money if they're so hoppy tell
them to jump you need walkaway power
kiddo
you've been sucked into this and you
it's like you're dying to own it I'm not
dying to own it nothing I heard here
just really flips my lid you're it's a
decent price but the rest of it is yeah
you know I I can duplicate what they're
doing and go buy some cars and hire some
drivers and driving trainers and start
up in a parking lot tomorrow and I can
probably do it cheaper than 800 grand
and steal their customers so we'll get
their customers buy better pricing and
better service because I think these
people can be beat in that category so
you know what you want to do I'm not
doing that deal I'm not doing that deal
based on the debt and I'm sure its cred
not putting up earnest money this on a
deal on a contract that's different than
the original term sheet the original
letter of intent was this is basic
business acumen here hey thanks for the
call